Fox News has sent a cease and desist
letter to fired propagandist Tucker
Carlson telling him he's got to stop his
Twitter show because he's actually under
contract with Fox News until December 31
2024. this would of course be
extraordinarily damaging to Tucker
Carlson if he was sidelined through the
entire election cycle up to and
including the November of 2024 election
and the seven or so weeks beyond that
Tucker Carlson launched the show on
Twitter to much fanfare with Elon Musk
but maybe uh not so much fan Fanfare
once we saw how disastrous the actual
program was harmeet Dylan who represents
Tucker Carlson says Fox News continues
to ignore the interests of its viewers
not to mention shareholder obligations
although it's not really clear that
that's an argument that Tucker is not
under contract until 2024.